[Music]
i need some help with my marriage next
thing i know she sent me a text in in
january saying i'm ending this marriage
i'm moving out of the house and and that
was that i can't tell if you are having
a trouble facing reality because this
doesn't help with your marriage this is
coming to terms with your wife has left
you
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
oloney's show
what's happening
hope you're doing well
man i don't watch the news very much
and so i catch it like you know
five minutes a week or something like
that
and
i mean man
things are bonkers
i hope you're well
and
hope you are getting away from that mess
and getting involved locally in your
home with your neighborhood with your
friends
with your local archery club whatever i
don't know
local communities local church whatever
you're doing um
please please please turn the
devices off and be with humans please be
with humans
after the show of course after the show
so um this is uh this is my confession
my buddy ian simpkins
um
he's one of the smartest people i've
ever met he posted this on the internets
the other day
and it's one of those things that i
don't like i've scrolled through this
nonsense trying to figure out how to do
my job
and this is one that stopped me in my
tracks it's rare that happens but this
one did and all it says is this
rest can feel like stress
if busyness is how you medicate
i'll say that again
rest can feel like stress
if busyness is how you medicate
so i found myself
at the end of
book tour the end of the radio shows i
mean the i co-host the second largest
radio show in the country
this podcast is just bananas in terms of
numbers people listening to it hanging
on there and
then we come out with a
number one best-selling book and we hit
the road and we're all over the place
and i say we um i can't do this i don't
do any of this by myself there's a team
everywhere
and
then we landed the other day and we
exhaled and then it was uh
wednesday we landed the wednesday night
i was back up here thursday recording
more friday
then all of a sudden monday hit and it
was just like the day just kept going
and my body said hey we're gonna shut
you down
and i remember this feeling back if you
read if you've read my book i remember
this feeling from the very first chapter
when you start seeing stuff that's not
there you start hearing things and it's
your bot my about my body telling me
dude uh you're lonely you're not hanging
out with people you've been running
around the country
los angeles new york back to los angeles
to vegas to florida all over the place
texas and all over the place
you're lonely you're not sleeping
you're exercising three times a week in
sporadic instead of the normal routine
you have
we're about to shut you down if you
don't make some changes and
it's so great man i do this for a living
i tell other people hey here's some
changes you can make in your life
and it's
bizarre
to have that happen to me in real time
and realize no i gotta go make some
changes and so um
had some conversations with my wife
which were hard
and basically saying hey i gotta take my
foot off the gas for a minute and um
i struggle with that because busyness is
how i medicate if i'm just making
something new or building something new
or writing something new then i can keep
pushing and pushing and so
it's just me being honest just saying it
out loud if busyness is how you medicate
there will come a moment when your body
will say i'm out and that might look
like anxiety that might look like
depression that might look like i'm
quitting my job that might look like
returning a text to somebody that you
probably shouldn't be texting with for
various reasons going back to an abusive
relationship whatever the thing is your
body will say i'm out we got to go find
some medication and some distractions
somewhere else
so this is me committing
recommitting if you will it's been a
tough season it's been one of the most
extraordinary seasons of my life i
wouldn't trade it for anything
the relationships the friendships the
fun the excitement the joy all that
stuff and more most importantly is
getting to sit with
thousands and thousands of you
telling me about life change that you
are making by the way people say you
changed my life i didn't change anything
dude i run my mouth on a podcast
you're the one actually saying okay i'm
gonna have this hard conversation i'm
gonna go back to the gym i'm gonna call
my doctor i'm gonna go back on
medication i'm gonna go see a counselor
i'm gonna go see a counselor i'm gonna
see a counselor
i'm gonna knock on the door to a new
church and see what happens or i'm gonna
leave this church for good i'm out
um
y'all are doing the hard work and it's
just been the greatest honor of my life
to walk with you through that
and at the same time we're gonna keep
shooting the show of course we're gonna
keep doing everything we're doing but
i'm also gonna have a season here for
the next 30 days or so of getting my
body back in order my head back in order
my relationship's back in order just
hanging out doing some fun stuff tonight
me and my daughter go on a date she's
gonna dress up nice i'm gonna dress up
nice i'm gonna pick her up and we're
gonna go on a on a date and i'm looking
forward to it
and i will say this
kelly when i asked her last night
we go on a date with me
she said maybe and i was like dude my
high school heart can't handle another
baby dude she was like maybe i'll think
about it and this is why i love sheila
ah jeez she's trained my daughter well
unbelievable maybe all right so that's
it
rest can feel stressful if busyness is
how you medicate
we all gotta rest i'll take a break
recharge re refill the pitcher if you
will my friend will gudera says uh
he's a restaurateur and we're all just
waiters and waitresses filling other
people's water picture and if you don't
stop and refill your picture
um
you're not gonna have anything to share
with anybody else so
here's to a season of restoration and
here's a two season of what comes next
all right let's go to grace in duluth
what's up grace how are we doing
holy cow i'm talking to john baloney i i
just said the same thing holy cow i'm
talking to grace this is amazing
what's up how are you i'm good i'm good
how about you
i am a huge fan and it's an honor to
talk to you well thank you and i'm a
huge fan of yours also
huge both because i haven't been
exercising and huge
because just in size and scope so so
what's up how can i help you cool
um
so i have an eight-year-old daughter who
is
just everything that is wonderful in the
world full of sass energy heart all of
it um
but she's struggling and
i don't know how much of it is because
she has started going through puberty
and how much of it is due to abuse that
she's witnessed at home
so tell me about the abuse she's
witnessed
um
her dad had undiagnosed bipolar and he
was mentally emotionally
abusive to her he was mentally
emotionally physically
financially sexually abusive to me
she was six when she watched him like
inappropriately grope me and i would try
and push him away and say not from her
whatever
um she's asked me several times why
daddy touched your boobies when you
didn't want him to
um what was your answer
i said daddy's not
he was sick daddy we've talked about his
bipolar compared it to a teeter-totter
that everybody has emotions that go up
and down
daddy's teeter-totter is just really
really big is dad still living at home
um no i
we're divorced um i kicked him out i
realized
when i finally realized that he had
actually been raping me um
and then just knowing the how the abuse
was affecting her like she tackled a kid
at school that was picking on her friend
she made another kid bleed because they
were restraining her like
she was constantly tearful constantly
you know saying mommy can you tell daddy
to be nice to me because he would only
the only way he would speak to her would
be yelling
um so let me stop here let me stop here
yeah
i am
proud of you
for
doing a really hard thing
and there's a level of bravery and
strength that um
most people never understand what you've
experienced and
the choice to enter into being a single
mom
and
i'm proud of you for doing that
for you
for her for your legacy okay
i'm proud of you that's hard
you did the right thing um okay and by
the way
mental health diagnostics are a context
not an excuse
okay great
right so i don't care what diagnosis he
has
nobody gets to put his hands on you
nobody gets to sexually assault or rape
you nobody gets to hurt you or your
children right
i'm proud of you it's hard
i also know living with somebody with
bipolar makes you feel crazy is that
right
i still feel crazy i know you do
and so now we're going to enter into a
season of you reclaiming
your own two feet right
yeah okay
i'm proud of you it's hard hard hard
hard and you're a strong brave human
being do you have people in your life
that you can lean on
i have
i i do yeah okay
you cannot go forward alone and you know
that but make sure you got people you
can call or text at all hours of the
night okay so your question's about your
little one all right so tell me about
what she's experiencing because she's
got some school stuff that
i mean it's a very sh she's
um
she's experiencing a strong sense of
justice
yeah she has a very strong sense of
justice so if someone is wronging
someone she cares about or wronging her
she will fly off the handle she does not
um
she doesn't handle male discipline well
even if hey we've asked you to brush
your teeth three times you know
you need to do it now
um she doesn't handle any kind of male
sternness well it scares her yes um
so think of um from this point forward
um think of
men telling her what to do in her life
as um
uh
as a horror movie character with a
hatchet
right okay there's no there's no
processing it there's no making the next
right good choice it is a little child's
body that goes that is
pretty sure it's gonna die and it
responds accordingly okay and so that
healing looks like not being a little
more less sassy or a little more like
compliant it is i've got to heal a brain
that sees a man and sets off an alarm
right
she's been in counseling um
for over a year and a half she's also in
so she does like counseling with a
therapist but she also does skills
counseling
that teaches her how to
gives her tools on how to deal with her
anxiety look at context of situations
yelling at me yes because i wasn't
listening or were they yelling at me
because i mean so we've been doing all
of that but
i just like she
even i have to and i'm okay with it i
understand it but even i have to ask
permission to give her hugs and kisses
yes and her dad's dad unfortunately who
also has bipolar um
will will get on her for not giving him
a hug no no no no no no no give me a hug
yeah no no way and
that that ends today
that is today okay so here's here's what
here's what she's learning
she had a um
okay a couple things
when kids witness domestic violence and
by the way um i checked in with my
friend who's an expert in this before um
yeah uh i called her she's a savant and
she goes into these situations regularly
and um
so
i actually didn't know this as much as
i've worked with trauma and with little
ones that i didn't know this particular
thing that kids when they witness
the abuse like you experienced
their little bodies take it on as though
it happened to them
right and so i want you to your
counselor may have told you that i
didn't know it was that visceral i
didn't know i knew a kid who experienced
their parents i didn't realize that it
experienced in the way that she was
explaining it to me so
right they can it can the range of
effects for a kid to see this but
including they will tell the story as
though it happened to them okay
so all she's trying to figure out is
body autonomy and she doesn't have a
picture of that because the most
powerful beautiful wonderful strong
woman she's ever met had her body
taken over by somebody else
right and so i think the greatest gift
you can give her is teaching her body
boundaries meaning
you modeling for her
can i hug you can i high-five you and my
daughter has never witnessed sexual
abuse and i do this with her have you
heard me tell that story here
tons of times yeah um it's a big deal
that i i reach in because i like her
hugs make me feel better right they just
do and she knows that so she weaponizes
them because she's sick
and
i ask can i give you a hug and she'll
say no thank you
and then i will say cool and i'll move
on with my day okay so
no man no father-in-law that's when you
get between him and your daughter
and you say he does she does not have to
hug you in fact she will not hug you
anymore because you don't have a right
to her body
okay i feel good about that i feel
strong about that yeah
the mama bearing me just like
yes
yes and if he says um i have
then you don't have access to my child
anymore bye
right bye you just don't like i don't i
don't need you in my life in fact you're
more of a burden to my family than not
right
um so
do you have like a man i feel like i'm
interrupting you and just answering
because i have a visceral response to
this too and i know you live it so
um
tell me how i can help is there a
specific situation i can help you with
um
so
oh i so intended on
making this completely a hundred percent
about her and i feel selfish turning it
back on me a little bit hey listen um
listen so anything to do with your kids
well-being starts with mom starts with
dad i know okay so don't feel a second
of guilt you getting well is a
gr a great gift you can give your
daughter okay
so just a tiny bit more just a tiny bit
more back story um i've been in therapy
on and off for 20 years third depression
anxiety eating disorders ptsd i was
abused when i was eight assaulted at 19
raped at 21 so i have a what you would
call a rich backstory
a rich history i have hey i wouldn't
college be a psychology i went to speak
i went to college for psychology um
i would not call this a rich backstory i
would call this a devastating
set of like a devastating traumatic
story right but i also understand you've
got to smile to walk through days
sometimes so okay
so i've been in therapy now for the last
two and a half years i started before my
marriage is even over thinking that i
was the problem right how do i help her
continue to process through
all this abuse
when it is triggering for me
every single day yeah
it may be a moment where
um you need to go do an intensive
or you both go do an intensive
yeah because you need to pause if you
can afford it
um you need to
pause because
if you were the abuse started in your
life when you were eight then your body
looks at her and remembers that and
starts sounding the alarms right
it's a very common common response there
um
and her tension
she feeds off your attention
and i know that puts a ton of
responsibility on you
but she feeds off that and then tries to
solve it and right now she's solving it
with control and with justice and with
violence and with
sass and humor too right
which is probably how you probably solve
a lot of the problems in similar ways
you're funny you're silly you're all
that and you can
mama bear can come out too right
so
i think
whether it's an intensive or
you can model what getting well looks
like
and if that means you have to find
somebody that you highly highly trust
that's not related to this knuckleheaded
family
um and go for 30 days and get well at an
intensive or do a couple of weekends in
a row
modeling for her
like daddy hurt mommy
and when i was a little girl other
people hurt mommy too and mommy's gonna
go get well because mommy's worth being
loved and mommy's worth being safe
and mommy's gonna learn some things that
can help you
be safe too
yeah see what i'm saying and here's
here's where kids pick things up so
um
somebody let's say i'm just gonna make
somebody up okay so
um let's say a stranger wearing
i don't know
with a mustache was one of the people
who abused you as a kid
like your dad's friend who had a
mustache and you happen to find yourself
at a target with your daughter
and some dude with a mustache reminds
your body
your daughter will pick up on you
almost imperceptibly
squeezing her hand a little bit tighter
right her body knows we're not we're not
okay
everybody tense up and we get smaller
but disappear right and we're gonna get
to this next aisle
so that's the level here
and when i say um
doing the hard work an intensive getting
well here's what we're looking for
can i remember what happened without my
body taking off on me that's what we're
looking to do
and when i say taking off on me without
that trauma response happening okay
okay
you've been in counseling a long time
what are you getting from counseling
at first it was
am i the problem in my marriage and then
it was okay i'm gonna
pull the plug on my marriage and now i'm
gonna process through the divorce
um and all the abuse and everything and
we're it's been almost a year now that
we've been divorced so now i feel like
i'm ready to start going into like emdr
or some kind of intensive
um i was there at one point and then
covet happened and i couldn't do it okay
and then covet just put a magnifying
glass on his bipolar and that's when all
the abuse started and i'm locked in a
house with this guy
if you were my sister i would tell you
to start with the mdr
okay it's a great place to start
and um
and it may be that you end up on
medication for a season great it may be
that you end up at a 30-day inpatient
hanging out with people just doing
intensive groups all day great
wherever your healing journey takes you
let this thing stop with you
yeah yo what i mean
yeah
let it stop with you and you're gonna
get beat up on it you're gonna have
scars and you're worth the journey and
you're worth the trip
right
yeah
one thing i want to tell you okay and i
want you to head on the line i'm gonna
send you a copy of my of my book okay um
my new one i already have it oh you
gotta read it okay that's amazing you
did so good all right well i was gonna
tell you here's what happens next and
it's in there but i'm gonna tell you
this okay
sexual abuse takes people's autonomy
from them
somebody else takes their body from them
they take their worth from them and then
somehow the shame mechanism flips it
around as though it was your fault
yeah
living inside a relationship with an
abusive person does the same thing
sometimes living with untreated bipolar
does the same thing
and so here's what i want you to be
sometimes and it's going to sound awful
i don't want to equate the two but it
can be very similar
20 years in counseling
where you go every week or every other
week and just talk about your problem
over time it slowly lets the air out of
your power
your strength
when somebody sexually abused you they
take your power from you they take your
strength when you are in the house
locked up with a tiger who has bipolar
who refuses to do the work that it takes
to get well
it takes your power from you and so
moving forward i don't want you to go to
counseling anymore just to talk about
stuff
i want you to go to counseling
to form a connection
so that you can begin to heal and get
your power
back okay yeah so the journey here is
reclaiming your strength
and part of reclaiming strength is
learning trust it's learning how to
control your breathing it's learning how
to say no
when some man says
you have to give me a hug to your
daughter you get between them and smile
real big and say you leave my house with
us and your heart rate never even gets
up it doesn't even spike on you that's
how in control you are right listen
here's the other side of it
you're so strong you can just lay down
and go to sleep at night no meds no
netflix no instagram you just go to
sleep right and you sleep all night
and somebody texts you and you don't
even feel like looking you see what i'm
saying like this is about getting
grace's power back
okay
and what you're gonna find real quick
real quick
you are so much stronger than you think
holy smokes dude you are so much
stronger than you think and you've got
so much more power than you think
and it's it's less about i gotta like
there is some weightlifting you got to
do and there's some new skills you got
to learn but this is more about somebody
going into a barn and there's a like a
tarp over something and they rip that
tarp back
and there's a ferrari under there that
is brand stinking new
and that's you
and so what we're gonna do over the next
few months is we're gonna you're gonna
tell your therapist
i'm ready to start healing we spent a
year building relationship and rapport
great we are about healing now and i'm
gonna do whatever it takes
and
i'm gonna get control of my body i'm
gonna get my strength and my power back
and if the therapist is worth their salt
they're gonna say all right and they're
gonna stand up and rip that tarp off and
show you a mirror
that you're a ferrari ready to rock and
roll
so proud of you you can do it you can do
it you can do it and by the way your
daughter needs that level of strength
too okay your daughter needs that level
of strength too so continue to get her
the help and care that she needs
and man teach her how important
her words are when it comes to who's in
control of her body man she's lucky to
have you
let's go get well we'll be right back
john delonay here all right people
you're adults so i'm going to talk to
you like adults and it's going to be
hard for some of you to hear you ready
it's time to move on from the grandma
hand-me-down facebook marketplace deal
or the just plain old nasty junky
mattress it's ridiculous we upgrade our
smartphones every three months but we
hang on to the same uncomfortable lumpy
mattress for decades your sleep is too
important for that it's time to invest
in a good night's sleep with a high
quality mattress and for me that's dream
cloud i'm speaking from experience when
i say this is the easiest thing you can
do to start improving your life and your
health and dream cloud is making it even
easier with an offer exclusively for my
listeners
499 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's 749 in
accessories and savings and you'll get
pillows a mattress protector and luxury
sheets it's time to change your sleep
and your life visit dreamcloudsleep.com
daloni or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloney to get your new
mattress today and get 749
in savings
all right
we're back let's go to david in
charlotte what's up david
hey dr john how are you i'm partying man
what about you
i'm doing good hey listen i need some
help uh with my marriage
you have come to the right guy what's up
yeah all right so here's the deal um
i've been married for about 13 years
my wife and i have two beautiful
daughters ages 13 and 8
and in
in january my wife had surprised me by
moving out of the house
whoa why
well that's that's the thing she just
you know
um
the the disagreement
um it stemmed from
our finances um and i think she has a
little bit of a spending issue and
when she moved out
in january she had she was in debt
approximately thirty thousand dollars in
credit card debt
and
we can never get this this spending
issue that she has under control
and
it just it just it kept snowballing and
it kept getting worse and
you know then it led to communication
issues misunderst understandings and a
lot of hurt feelings between the two of
us and eventually we kind of just you
know we just stopped talking we stopped
communicating and
next thing i know she sent me a text in
in january saying
you know i'm i'm ending this marriage
i'm moving out of the house and um
and and that was that so uh fast forward
so just just before she
she moved out maybe like a week or two
before she moved out
my my older daughter
had found an inappropriate conversation
in her phone basically she was sexting
with another man another married man
so
um you know
the next morning i believe it was the
next morning my my daughter had told me
when i gave it right to school my
daughter told me what she found
and you know of course i was i was
really hurt
and
eventually i went in i went to my wife's
phone and i found it a couple days later
she had she left her phone on the
counter
and i was able to get on my wife's phone
and i found it
and
i was able to take some pictures and
some videos to see what was going on so
we i confirmed what my daughter had
found in her phone
are you still there yeah i'm here yeah
all right
so
after that
so she moved out in january
and
um ever since she moved out
she's been been very very distant
and
she she tried to take she tried to take
me to court uh to try to take custody of
the kids and so we went to court
and
she ended up losing in court so i have
the cust i have custody of the kids here
at the house so you you call your first
your first question to me is you want to
save your
help with your marriage
is your marriage over
is she fighting for this
i i i believe so uh yeah i mean you know
and it sounds like she moved out and
then she tried to take you to court
are you all still legally married or she
filed for divorce
well i i don't think she can sh
we can we can legally separate until
then you know next january
wow and then after i think because we
have to be living apart
for a year and then and then i think
everything finalizes i don't know after
that i've never heard that in my life
did you get attorneys
like a divorce attorney
yes yep okay and they said you just got
to sit on this for a year
right right and that's exactly it
because you know i wasn't physically
abusing her i wasn't emotionally abusing
her i wasn't yelling at her and
you know basically the last year of our
relationship she wasn't around in the
evenings
to help out with
with the girls um you know she started
working out and developed this insane
you know workout habit that she's been
at the gym okay hold on hold on
did not like the life she
had found herself in
and
it's super common
to have kids in the age ranges you're in
and somebody look in the mirror and say
this can't be all there is for me
then they go lose a ton of weight and
they go work out like crazy and then
they start cheating
and then they
fantasize about a new existence
and they think it's just going to be
simple i'm just going to leave and then
i'll get all my kids when i want but not
when i don't want and then i'm going to
have this great body and this new
sexual partner and then life's going to
go on great and my bank account is going
to be exactly how it was all that
and so somebody it sounds like she's
been cheating on you for a while man
and it sounds like she's been out of
this marriage for a while
this isn't a
question about
i i
i can't tell if you are having a trouble
facing reality
or if you have
she has told you no i think i'm coming
back or you have a fantasy about her
coming back like
where are you because this doesn't help
with your marriage this is
this is you coming to terms with your
wife has left you
and what is life going to look like now
correct right right you know and i think
you hit it on the head and i think it's
all the above okay okay um
i love her very much and you know um
it's hard to see her go and okay so
listen listen you know i'm having a
heart she's been gone for a year
been gone for a year
and now listen here's what's really
crappy about about this
she's probably been gone emotionally for
two years
if not right
and so when she finally left
that was the end for her and that was
just the beginning for you
correct and so there is it feels like a
gap between the two of you there's a
clear gap she your wife left you okay
but there's a gap that feels bigger than
the grand canyon because you're like oh
oh this is serious let's talk about this
and in her head no i just put a period
at the end of that sentence it's over
correct right and then there's all the
legal rigamaru which the lawyers get
paid the longer it goes on
and i have utmost i'm one of the few
people in the world i defend lawyers to
the end of the earth because i think
that they play an important role i also
think that they get paid to keep things
going
yeah and so if you haven't already i
would find an attorney that says i need
this to be over as soon as possible and
i'm not interested in waiting a calendar
year
you are prolonging
your own agony and misery and you are
choosing to not grieve
you see what i'm saying
right exactly
and here let me tell you this is gonna
be hard we're about to say i'm just
telling you the truth
you're dragging your daughters through
this
and you still call her my wife and you
still call her mom and you still call
her yeah but your mother
dude your wife walked out on y'all
you're one of those guys now
and the question is what kind of life
are you going to build for you and for
your daughters out of the ashes of what
just happened
right and that starts with you facing
reality
is that fair and you hear me say this as
someone who loves you not someone who's
like talking crap at you right you hear
hear him saying i'm not trying to be a
jerk right i'm just trying to say hey
man
right
this is me having a conversation with
somebody in the hospital when i have to
be the one that says hey
um
there is no brain activity
your partner is dead
is it it's time to let go and they're
like no no we can that's me telling you
this sounds like this thing's over right
okay am i out to lunch am i wrong
right no you're you're right on the
money let me ask you this this is
another one of my questions
so
you know if
if we were to back up you know we had
stopped communicating it was you know
because of the spending so my question
to you is
you know if she's in that much credit
card debt and she just doesn't stop
spending
do i should i have let her
continue to spend in order for her to be
happy to try and hopefully you know save
the marriage if i knew this was going to
be the case or should i have put my foot
down sooner and say hey enough is enough
and if at that point
the way to stop spending the way you're
asking that question tells me that there
was some major dysfunction in your
marriage
because you're not her dad
and i put my foot down with my children
i don't put my foot down with my wife
because my wife and i work our butts off
months in advance to be on the same page
about just about everything and when we
get off the same page
we circle back and say not hey this
particular thing
like so i'm the guy in my house i'll
just spend money like i'm an idiot right
i'm a what do you call a free spirit
that's what my friend rachel calls
i gotta see a thing i work real hard i
just wanna go get it
when i do that my wife doesn't come at
me and say i can't believe you spent
money that's not how she asks me
she said hey you and i've got goals that
we all agreed on
and
something must be going on in your life
for you to violate these goals what's
going on man
because you don't seem like you're okay
right that's different then you can't do
this
because she's not my mom
she's my
she is part of me the way you refer to
your wife as she's running up her money
you've got a you've got a pronoun issue
in your marriage that's y'all's money
because y'all are all right you see what
i'm saying so something up got separated
it might have been the way you always
had this thing
or maybe your wife was tired of you
acting like her father or maybe she kept
acting like a child and you were left to
try to clean up the i don't know what
the challenge was but we got to a place
where so to answer your question
directly if i had that exact same
situation in our house
the way i would have it the conversation
i would have is
hey to my wife
you and i agreed we want to get out of
debt you and i agreed we don't want to
have a house payment as crazy as that is
you and i agreed we're going to drive
crummy cars until we pay off our house
and get our kids fully funded for
college that they're going to have less
worries than we did
we've agreed on these things
and your actions are not in alignment
with what we agreed a
are we okay but
here's the thing she wouldn't she thinks
life is too short to save at all so she
won't even
we're always so so negative in the
account so a
she's very immature very very immature
and b
you
around here we call it financial
infidelity she was cheating on you with
money
it's a power play it's financial abuse
okay and i would treat the infidelity as
such
okay life trust me life's too long to
not save
it's way too long you're not safe right
we have to
it's just immaturity
but here's the thing
it is a symptom of the immaturity
it's not the thing to be solved what's
to be solved is a decision to act like
an adult
and yes at some point if you are married
to somebody and they are draining your
account and they were putting your
family at risk and they are cheating on
you with their money
you have to make a decision for the
safety of your children the safety of
you the safety of like this becomes
abuse it becomes infidelity and i've
said this before on the show i think
infidelity is a much bigger conversation
than who puts what body part where and
with who
infidelity is are we on the same page we
agreed to be this
and you opted out
right and now we're gonna have a harder
conversation cheating is a much bigger
picture than making out with somebody
and so uh all that to say is
this
money is a symptom of a much bigger
issue
bottom line your wife has laughed
and i i'm literally i can hear it on you
you need to spend some time
there not with will my marriage
she's gone she's been gone for a year
and now it's about
grieving this thing sitting in this
thing and then what happens next
hang on the line jenna's gonna send you
a copy of my new book i want you to read
it straight through okay i want you to
read us straight through
because the back half of that book is
what do we do now
and i want you to go find a counselor
or a couple of buddies that aren't going
to be like yeah bro but are going to
listen to you as you say the words my
wife has left me and my marriage is over
and i don't know what to do next
okay and i want you to rally your
daughters up and say hey i'm coming to
terms with mom has left i want you to
call an attorney and say i need this
faster than a year and maybe that's the
law in north carolina i don't know good
god it's crazy i can't imagine that is
um
but i'm sure somebody can write me and
let me know what the deal is but
anyway
i'm sorry man
i'm sorry
the only only the light here i can offer
you is there's healing on the back end
of this okay there's healing on the
other side but you have to walk through
it we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your
healing better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with you and your
therapist you never have to even see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy plus you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours and today
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back let's go to
oh let's try caitlyn in fresno
california what's up caitlin
hey dr john i need help kind of
processing through the recent school
shooting in texas ah yeah
yeah i kind of do too can we do that
together
yeah absolutely so i want to give you a
little background before we go into it
because it'll help you
understand where i'm coming from
i'm a current teacher in an elementary
school and before i was a teacher i was
in emergency services for about nine
years and i'm currently trying to leave
and go back into
emergency services more on the law
enforcement side so i have a lot
rattling around in my brain regarding
both sides of that shooting
so you told me about the professional
stuff
you've been a teacher in a classroom
and you've played that scenario out
in your head right
yes every almost every week yes
um
you've also been ems
and you've shown up not to seem that bad
but you've shown up to some stuff right
right so when they say
bodies or
children or you have a different
visceral feeling than most because most
of us
yeah that's right because you've shown
up on a scene when a child isn't mated
right yes yes and you've watched people
that it's a it's a different kind of cry
nothing comes out it's almost like a
throw up cry at the same time you've
seen parents do that right
yeah yes
so what makes you so i tell you that to
tell you i want you to honor your body
in this because you've seen this stuff
this is a part of you this is different
this is not an academic exercise or just
some stuff you saw or learned
this is for real is that fair
yes okay
why do you want to be a cop
i feel like i really miss parts of the
tangible
elements that i had at ems and i know
in the school system we are helping all
these kids but i miss the tangibility
and the problem-solving components of
that world and okay of my skill set so
one i don't know how who
i don't know how you came into the world
but i wish more people had a spirit of
cert you're like you just are put on
earth to serve right
i believe so yeah that's so great man so
great you're amazing
um all right so what do you this is
going to sound awful but
i process what happened in uvalde
differently with different groups
with my
law enforcement friends
it's guttural
because they see what appears to be
catastrophic screw-ups
right
you see that too
yes so these are my buddies who are in
badge and they go what are you doing
and
they feel the heat of everybody in the
world blaming police for everything and
here they are getting back in the car
and going back on patrol again today
right
yeah and they also know that you can
train all day seven days to sunday when
you are in a building
where bullets are flying
and there are children
that everything is different than you
think it's gonna be i've been in a
building
full of uh students during an active
shooter i've been there it's different
than we trained it's the same but it's
different in your body you know what i'm
saying you've been there
so i also am a parent of a six year old
and so i grieve that with parents
differently
i'm also a texan
who
has guns
and i
like what what is ha and i also
have common sense and i'm not a [ __ ]
right so it's it's a it's one of those
across the board spec like i'm grieving
this in 50 different ways and i'm trying
to solve it tomorrow for my community in
50 different ways right so i tell you
all those things to say you have
permission on this show
to grieve it across the board
but i want you to speak into it like
how can i help you with what you which
particular thing you're struggling with
i think because of both sides of that
i kind of feel like i know too much
and in the sense of like
a lot of teachers can kind of go around
and say they don't know what they don't
know in regards to faces and tactical
kind of things and i almost know just
enough to know too much to know that we
are
i mean for a lack of better terms kind
of sitting ducks in these classrooms in
a lot of ways and so i'm having a hard
time kind of processing that in in
almost a point where i'm
finding myself having a hard time
respecting my colleagues and and that
lack of that chain of command and i
don't know if they would know what to do
like
let me let me let me tell you no
exactly that's not their job but no
right having a hard time with that part
of it um so
two things you can do with that
number one is you can feel that okay
your feelings are right like you you are
trained as an ems person or as a law
enforcement person
to walk into a room or a situation and
say this is not safe this is not safe
this scene is not secure right let's say
you're trained to walk into a room and
scan the room
you're trained as a teacher
that when people lack insight or
knowledge into a certain thing that your
job as a teacher is to help
bridge that gap
yeah and so
feeling that and understanding is
this is why things like 911 this is why
things like covid this is why things
like these shootings are so unmooring is
that we live with a certain level of
that's all going to be all right
and when you spend time with military
folks you spend time with first
responders they go yeah but it might not
be because i've seen it right
and that was the joke with my old man he
was a homicide detective it was always
a hundred percent of his day was dealing
with things that never happened
nobody gets hacked up with a hatchet but
on tuesday they did and that's where he
spent most of his day right and nobody
ever gets in a 17 car pile up it
except on wednesday and that's where he
spent all of his day right so as a
police officer you are trained to walk
into situations that no one ever sees
and you're trying to walk in and
try to make sense of it and as a teacher
you
you teach people and so a way you can
make here's the words how am i going to
make meaning of these feelings okay okay
i'm going to offer a class
i'm gonna any teacher who wants in on it
i'm gonna teach you um here's the right
way to do that hey principal i'm i'm
willing to i've got a background in this
i'm willing to
teach the
the folks here about this i'm willing to
hold a small group i'll get coffee and
donuts um and have all the teachers who
want to show up and just to debrief like
a cis like a critical incident stress
management like a a debrief how are all
y'alls teachers everybody okay this was
what happened to scary and we all
realized we're pretty freaking
vulnerable in here you see i'm saying
like how am i gonna make what am i gonna
do how am i gonna make meaning of this
and then be very
be very graceful with the teachers the
people who cannot wrap their head around
it
right it's one of the arguments that i
hear like we just need to arm all the
teachers
hey you work with teachers no you don't
right no but b
that's not you can't even pull up a
phone to take a picture of a celebrity
you think you're going to be able to do
that in the classroom there you go right
and so that's a political thing right
but the idea is um
some people cannot put their head there
they can't go there i'm going to be
graceful with them right i'm that's not
that i'm not gonna beat them up for i'm
not gonna you don't know what's coming
it's that's not helpful that's just
gonna shut them down further right
yeah um ultimately the question is do
you wanna stay a teacher or you wanna go
to law enforcement and
what role of service do you wanna be a
part of and here's what i'll tell you
there are and you know this idiot
teachers i've worked with them i was one
actually
um there are teachers who aren't great
no teachers are incredible
there are going to be police officers
who are remarkable and they spend every
minute of their life wanting to help and
love and serve their communities and
there's going to be idiots
who screw it up
and the goal is to please get those
folks out and to continue to support and
honor and love those who are really
trying to do the best they can with what
they got does that make sense so yeah
all i had to say is
because you're a servant there's not
going to be an arena you go into where
it's going to be perfect and that it's
going to be free from tons of outside
armchair quarterbacks
and it's for you you've got to always
remember why you're doing this in the
first place
yeah i kind of have to ground myself in
that so that it goes
yeah greg hey
nothing else just remember
um
i know enough to know that in the middle
of the night if something goes down i'm
not call 9-1-1
yeah know what i mean and you you will
be the person who shows up for me and my
little kids and my wife
and my dogs and my chickens except you
can let the chickens go they're fine
they drive me crazy
right here i'm saying like remember me
yeah remember my family remember my
little kids when the news is crazy or
when you see some police officer do some
stupid racist idiot thing that's not
everybody it's not most everybody
and let's remember the family on the
other end of that phone does that make
sense
it does yeah
um
i don't know if that's helpful or not i
feel like i just been talking a lot i
feel like like hey let's process this
together and i'm going to talk for 10
minutes without you without breathing
right
um
okay i just threw a lot at you how are
how are you
i'm good i think um
i i also i like the idea of the class
and i think i need to kind of figure out
a way to also bridge it
up to like the district office level too
in terms of like
physical things that we can do around
the school
um so a great thing you can do is to
pilot it pilots to work like uh pilot it
practice it give it a shot
and if it goes well with five or six
teachers in your little grade unit then
maybe the principal lets you do it at
your campus and if that goes well then
you and your principal approach
the region or the school district and
you see what i'm saying so don't go
don't be like i've got a program
man they're getting bombarded
but start start with a human part hey i
know five teachers around me they're
kind of freaked out we're gonna get
we're gonna get coffee in the evening
we're gonna go to sonic get some drink
and we're just gonna sit in a circle and
say how are you and how are you and how
are you because a lot of teachers are
replaying this stuff in their head
and they're terrified because they've
got nobody to talk to about it
yeah and you can
think one way
and yeah i i think i just see it
differently and
but i also have that humanity
and compassion side of the teacher and
so that's right that's right
okay the world is better because you're
in it katelyn i'm really grateful for
you
thank you doctor john so two things
remember your feelings are real and you
get to have them
and then the question we always want to
get to is how am i going to make meaning
of this what do i do next
right
and man as being able to be a teacher
and law enforcement and
such important shout outs to our law
enforcement folks such important shout
outs to our teachers
and such
all everybody grieving from all over
this mess and to my brothers and sisters
who are police officers with kids who go
to school
um the ones i've talked to this has been
mass man weeping and sadness and i can't
believe that they just sat in the
hallway for all those things and the
tactical questions and the kid questions
and the
follow-up questions all of it man
as a country we gotta grieve
and we got a bunch of follow-up just a
mess man what a mess
be like caitlyn find places in your
community where you can serve now where
you can throw fits at their water
balloons and throw rocks and throw
bricks and scream or you can actually
sit down with people and serve we'll be
right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
get some rest
get the
the healing that you need
own reality
unreality
and man it's okay to really really love
what you do your community your
professional groups and to be really
frustrated when they mess up and to want
to be a part of healing
or to hold judgment when you think
they've messed up i'm gonna hold on
because it's not my place to judge just
yet
i'm not gonna get caught up in the
political
i'm gonna go serve
the heavy show today but it also has a
lot of lessons for moving forward
as we wrap it up man this great kate
bush song
song's called running up that hill i
deal with god and it goes like this
if only i could i'd be running up that
hill
it doesn't hurt me
do you wanna know how it feels do you
wanna know you wanna know that it
doesn't hurt me do you want to hear
about the deal that i'm making yeah it's
you and me
and if only i could i'd make a deal with
god and i'd get him to swap our places
be running up that road be run up that
hill be running up that building if only
i could
is there so much hate for the ones we
love tell me we both matter don't we yes
it's you and me
it's you
and me
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode pretty
simple question uh luckily for you it's
not a dark topic
[Laughter]
or is it my son is asking a lot of
questions about my dad
and my husband and i don't know how to
answer his
questions about his death in an
age-appropriate way the truth about um
his death is really heavy that most
adults have a really hard time grasping
how we doing
um i'm doing okay oh so not good at all
not good at all huh well i overheard my
husband's friends
and him
making fun of me she insisted on asking
him if
he felt like he had downgraded on his ex
oh gee
yeah who who was yeah light-skinned and
slim
and he said
maybe oh
gosh wait hold on hold on he told he
told her
[Music]